you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution is it true that
all mammals only shed teeth once
there are exceptions to every rule
so
the fun exceptions are manatees dugongs
um some kangaroo species
um
and then the opposite side of that scale
is some types of shrews actually replace
their baby teeth
like the tooth starts to grow as a nub
in the womb
and then when they come out they're
already like ready to have their adult
teeth so those are the exceptions
um that i know of i'm sure there's more
but so the manatee is doing it
continuously
yeah they're kind of because they're
kind of closer to elephants where they
have like these teeth at the back that
kind of move
forward continuously because because
elephants also do this they have this
set number they don't have just forever
continuously
regenerating teeth but they have a set
number that slowly move forward as they
wear away the front ones and so there is
technically like a conveyor belt a
really slow one uh of teeth just going
forward because if you don't have
continuous teeth you starve when you're
eating tough stuff right
and then
rodents
you know rodents i mean their front
teeth are continually growing do they
actually lose them too at a point or do
they just have one set questions
oh i don't know
i feel like they must lose their their
first step i really don't know i
actually don't know they are the weird
the weirdest
probably well as far as teeth go the
weirdest
actually i shouldn't say that because
we've got things like narwhal
there's all sorts of weird teeth out
there but yeah mammals do some weird
stuff with their teeth that's for sure
after our conversation yara was too
curious so she googled it
okay it says
only one set of teeth their entire life
i'm not sure how much i believe that
this is rap behavior.org
yeah
i mean it kind of makes sense because
even the molars grow forever right
because they grind them constantly
so so yes and no um so molars they do
replace ones um when they're in in mice
and and most other
um rodents
i'm just wondering if it's like one of
those secret like oh they have like a
toothbrush that they replace in in utero
uh and then the incisor you know comes
out and it's fine um there are other
animals that have like continuously
wearing teeth like horses horses
have their teeth are continuously
erupting have you ever seen those like
horse skulls that have the jaw cut you
can see how long the roots are no no you
should google that that's crazy okay so
they have extremely long roots and their
teeth are just continuously moving
upwards and it's that ligament that we
were talking about that keeps like kind
of just letting them spring upwards and
they just keep grinding and grinding and
it's not forever but it's like long
enough for a horse that i think the
oldest horse is like 60 something and it
still had teeth so yeah
it's a pregnant system with horses
instead of having just enamel on the
outside they have enamel like swirled
through the middle too right
elephants too yeah all these herbivores
that need all that extra surface area to
um
chew up plant matter basically they
their crowns are super like unfolded and
it's that infolding that helps us
identify like fossil forces fossil
rhinos fossil cows whatever they all
have very distinct interfolding but the
interfolding is cementum
uh enamel and dentine cementum is just
like like dentine but it attaches the
dentine to bone it's a it's a very
mammalian thing it's not pretty much
it's it's not in a whole lot of other
animals but it's really cool so yeah
they interfold all their teeth and
elephants have the same thing a lot of
herbivores mammal mammalian herbivores
have that like inter-folding yeah it's
really neat to look at how
well you can see it really well in in
horses
that that they have the various distinct
differences between the the dentine so
that
is denting more like bone
good question uh i'll answer you after
my postdoc how about that okay because
it's actually something i'm looking at
uh because those early early fish that
have
like that bony dermal bone exoskeleton
stuff that's covered in dentine
um that's one of the questions that i
want to ask um
basically are the two tissues related
and how and
who invent which one came first you know
right the dentine or the bone
so yeah
right i don't know the tooth core like a
human tooth the core is denting enamel
on the outside yeah and horses have that
all
mixed in there so there's little veins
it looks like little veins of yeah
enamel inside the the middle of the
tooth
but it's interesting because i
i've been chewing my nails since i was a
kid
and so it actually wore through the uh
god the enamel on your incisors yeah
yeah on my ins so yeah and so it's only
one of my incisors that has the enamel
worn through and so now the the dentine
is exposed and it just erodes faster
than everything else and the dentist is
like uh
you shouldn't do that
but
it's too late now but it's it is
interesting to see i actually get to
feel in real time you know the
difference between enamel and dentine
and then you see it in horses you see it
and all these other animals that
constantly grind their teeth it's just
really neat to be able to see that for
them it's actually kind of an adaptation
because the dentine wears down first
makes a groove and then the little parts
of enamel act as
kind of like a
sharp grinding
yeah differences in texture and
differences in topology help them chew
yeah yeah so you've you've come you've
almost got a chisel in the middle of a
molar
exactly that's how it works out it's
it's just it's so neat and then
rodents of course they only have enamel
on the front and it's denting on the
back
so when they grind their teeth
it just automatically sharpens it's
brilliant yeah yeah i mean it's such an
amazing i mean i'm always careful of
using the word design but i mean it is
it's such an amazing like adaptation and
then their back teeth are
uh
depending on which rotating you're
looking at they also some of them have
like some interfolding uh in their back
teeth as well i think squirrels do i
could be wrong yeah yeah
and then rabbits
rabbits i'm pretty sure do i used to
have a rabbit's skull
and
the lagomorphs yeah me and rabbits are
not true rodents but but they're pretty
much i mean for all intensive purposes
when it comes to their teeth they might
as well be uh ever-growing incisors and
then they're they're crazy molars so
yeah
well that's it for this clip but don't
worry i post clips regularly and every
thursday i post completely fresh content
make sure you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome